[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
NANCY KANWISHER: So we're
talking about navigation--
how you know where
you are and how
you can get from here to
wherever else you want to go.
And last time we talked about
just the general problems that
arise in navigation,
and we talked
about the parahippocampal
place area
and other parts
of the brain that
are involved in navigation.
So today we're going
to continue that,
but we're going to talk more
about the actual populations
of neurons in your head that
are involved in doing this.
And we'll talk about
a particular aspect
of the problem of navigation,
which is called reorientation.
That is what happens when
you lose your bearings,
and you need to figure
out where you are again.
Reset your internal
map of where you are.
And then we'll
talk about the idea
that this whole
system for navigation,
cool as it is and fascinating
as navigation itself is,
is even more interesting because
there's increasing evidence
that we use that
same system for lots
of other aspects of
high level cognition
that have nothing to
do with space per se.
OK that's-- and then we'll
have a quiz, a short quiz.
That's the agenda.
Here we go.
So the basic problems
of navigation are, one,
where am I?
And two, how do I get from here
to wherever else I want to go?
And as I mentioned last time,
we can break down each of these
into a bunch of
different components
and facets of that question.
So when we want to
know where we are,
that can involve recognizing
a familiar location.
So if you see a photograph
or you were plunked down
spontaneously in an
environment someplace you know,
you would visually recognize
it, and that would be
one way to know where you were.
Like, this is my living room.
Even if that location
is unfamiliar
and you're plunked
down at random,
you still have some idea of
what kind of a place this is.
Am I in a natural environment?
An urban environment?
Am I inside?
Am I outside, et cetera?
And finally, you
would have some sense
of where you are with respect
to the immediate bounding
structures in your
immediate environment.
Like, for example, where
you are in this room.
As I'm talking to
you right now, I'm
aware that there's
a wall behind me.
That kind of immediate
spatial location.
In terms of questions
that arise when
we have to figure out how do we
get from here to wherever else
we want to go.
If you can directly see
or hear your destination,
then you have the
simplest possible kind
of navigation strategy.
You just go toward that thing.
OK, that's called beaconing, and
it's like the minimalist case.
Works great if you can see
or hear your destination.
But when you can't,
you need to know,
where am I in my
broader understanding
of the layout of my environment
and where is my goal.
And for that, you need a
mental map of your environment,
and we'll talk more
about that today.
That's why it's in red.
You also need to know
your current heading
in that environment.
It's not enough to know
in my map of the world,
I am here with a dot.
You needs to know
which way you're
facing in that map
of the world in order
to plan your navigation, and
we'll talk about that too.
We also need to know what
routes are possible from here.
So I may want to go over to
Stata and get a cup of coffee.
But I can't go this way.
I've got to go around because
I can't go through that glass.
OK, and so finally, this
whole magnificent system
that enables us to
process all this stuff
works pretty impressively.
But every once in a while,
something will go wrong,
and it will get the wrong
signal, and then we're lost.
And so then we need a way
to regain our bearings,
and we'll talk about that too.
So last time I talked about
a bunch of brain regions
that are implicated
in perceiving scenes
and in navigation.
We talked about the
parahippocampal place area
right here and this region over
here, formerly known as TOS,
now known as OPA.
You don't need to
remember all that.
It's the bit that's out
on the lateral surface
that we can zap
because it's out there.
And both of those regions
seem to be involved broadly
in perceiving the shape
of space around you.
We also talked a bit about
retrosplenial cortex,
that region that's
hiding in the sulcus
here that you can see better
when you mathematically
unfold the sulcus, there it is.
Responds more to
scenes than objects.
And that region seems to
be involved in something
like getting your bearings--
that is the location
and orientation of where
you are with respect
to your cognitive
map and environment.
OK, so to make that
a little more vivid,
I gave you one description
of a patient before,
but here's from another study.
Patients with damage to
retrosplenial cortex--
so here's from a
recent article--
in every case, the
patient with this damage
was able to recognize landmarks
in their neighborhoods
and retained a sense
of familiarity.
I know that place.
That's the coffee shop
five blocks from my house.
But despite that,
none of those patients
were able to find their way
in familiar environments,
and all but one were
unable to learn new routes.
So they can recognize the visual
form of a particular place,
but they don't know
how to relate that
to their cognitive
map of the world
and therefore plan
a route from there.
OK, so the part
that I only alluded
to at the end-- yes, question?
AUDIENCE: OK, is the
retrosplenial cortex
the home to the cognitive
maps, or is it--
NANCY KANWISHER: Great question.
We don't exactly know.
The typical story is that
the home of the cognitive map
is the hippocampus, which
we're about to talk about next
for reasons I will tell you.
But all of this is a very
active area of research.
It kills me every time
I do these lectures.
I look at my old
notes, and I think
here are these 10
other awesome studies,
and then I try to fit them in,
and then they just don't fit.
So actually one
question I want to ask
you guys after this lecture
is, should I in future,
either later in this course
or in future courses,
allocate even more time, or do
you guys feel like OK, enough
already with navigation.
But I just think it's
the coolest system.
So there's lots of
work exactly trying
to answer that kind of question.
And I'll give you
a current snapshot
of the approximate
state, but all of this
is in flux and very much
actively investigated.
OK, so cognitive map,
what do we mean by that?
Just to remind you of this
classic study from the 1940s
in rats, where the rat,
when they learned this route
and then went up here and
found their gold block,
the rat immediately comes
out and goes straight
toward the goal.
Telling you they've learned
something much more interesting
than the series of left and
right turns to get to the goal.
They must have done something
much more like actually learned
the layout of space and the
relative position of that goal
so they could come
up with a new vector
to get there when the
original route was blocked.
OK, and you guys
can do this too.
When your route is blocked,
you come up with a novel route.
And you do that by having some
knowledge of your environment,
something tantamount
to that in your head,
some version of that.
And further, you know
where you are in that map.
Like right now, you
know where you are.
Now here's the cool thing--
specific neurons
in your hippocampus
right now are firing telling
you that you are right there.
So these neurons are
called place cells,
and this is what they do.
OK, so I'll be a place
cell, or rather what I'll do
is I will act out the
activity of a place cell
by a series of clicks I
will make as I walk around.
So imagine there's an
electrode in my hippocampus,
and you are hearing the
activity of a single neuron
in my hippocampus
as I walk around.
And here's what it would do.
You'd hear background firing.
So it's going to go click,
click, click, click, click.
Noisy background firing.
Click, click, click,
click, click, click,
click, click, click, click.
Click, click, click,
click, click, click, click,
click, click, click,
click, click, click, click.
Click, click, click, click,
click, click, click, click,
click, click, click,
click, click, click, click.
Click, click, click, click,
OK, I'm not going
to go down there.
Click, click, click, click,
click, click, click, click.
Click, click, click,
Click, click, click, click,
click, click, click, click.
Click, click, click,
Click, click, click, click,
click, click, click, click,
click, click, click,
click, click, click, click.
So that's one neuron
that fires only when I'm
right over there, that place.
It's not where I'm
facing over there.
It's not what I'm
looking at particularly.
It's when I'm right there.
OK, that's a place cell.
And so there's lots of place
cells in your hippocampus
that do that, and they do
it for different locations
in your environment.
And all of this was first
worked out, of course,
in rodents, who
were running around
who had electrodes
in their hippocampus,
but where those electrodes were
connected with a loose tether
so that the rodent could move
around in their environment
while recording from individual
neurons in the hippocampus.
OK, so that's the setup.
And so I'm going to show you
a movie of an aerial view
of a rodent moving around--
a rat moving around
in its environment.
Can you see the
little rat there?
And what's happening
is this video
is tracing out the rat's
path with the light gray.
And every time that-- and
it's recording from one
neuron-- every time that neuron
fires, it makes a red dot.
So this is obviously sped up.
But as the rat moves
around in his environment,
you see an accumulation
like more firing
when the rat is right there.
It's not which direction
the rat is going
through when he goes there.
Just basically
whenever he passes
through that in any
direction, neurons
fire more than anywhere else.
And then if we take
that and blur it,
as scientists like to do to
make nice idealized pictures,
that is the place
cell for that neuron.
That is the place in
space that that animal has
to be to make that neuron fire.
Yeah, question.
AUDIENCE: Is it one dimension?
I mean, can multiple places
be mapped to the same neuron?
NANCY KANWISHER:
That's complicated.
In an immediate environment
like this, generally not.
OK, I'll show you some
examples in a moment.
It's more complicated
if you follow
that cell when the animal
moves to a new location.
So let me say a few more things,
and then if it's not clear,
I'll take questions.
Oops, we're going
to see that again.
OK, right so in answer
to Sasha's question, here
are a bunch of place cells
from a rodent exploring
the same environment.
So you might say, well,
there's a hotspot here
and a little sub one there.
But in general,
most of these cells
respond with a hotspot in a
particular single location
in this particular environment.
OK, did you have a different
question about that?
AUDIENCE: Yes, so
that all depends
on the rat being conscious
of the fact that it's
in that place?
NANCY KANWISHER: Uh-huh.
Uh-huh.
If the rat was anesthetized
or if he was blindfolded
and you passively moved
him around in that space
and he had no idea-- no
way to tell where he was,
that wouldn't work.
However, if the rat
knows the environment
and then you do this in
a darkened room where
he's actively locomoting
around, these things
will still work pretty
well because rats
are very good at keeping
track of where they are, even
without visual cues if
they know the environment.
They'll have other
cues like tactile cues,
and they will know how far
they went in each direction.
Remember I talked briefly
about the Tunisian ants
doing dead reckoning.
Keeping track of their vector
and speed at each moment
and integrating the whole
thing to know where they are.
That's called dead reckoning.
Rats are pretty
good at that too.
Another question over here?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: For the
place cells, do
they have a map as
well [INAUDIBLE]..
NANCY KANWISHER:
We'll get there.
Great question.
I'll just give you the answer.
No, they don't.
It's too bad.
They could have.
They could have
been all organized,
but it's actually a
little complicated.
How would you organize them?
What if you learned more stuff
off of the edge of space?
What if you had a whole other
piece of your hippocampus?
It would be inconvenient,
so maybe that's
why it doesn't work.
Whereas with visual space,
your retinotopic information
always stays the same.
We don't have to suddenly
add a whole new part
of retinotopic space,
thereby screwing up
our retinotopic
maps in the brain.
I'm just making that up
as a possible reason.
I don't know if that's why.
Yeah, sorry, behind you
David, tell me your name.
AUDIENCE: Justice.
NANCY KANWISHER:
Yeah, right, hi.
AUDIENCE: So I was wondering
if you're in a smaller space
comparatively or a
bigger space, will
areas of these specific place
cells, what they're mapping to,
will they also
scale up right now?
NANCY KANWISHER: That's
a great question.
I don't know the answer.
My guess is they'll scale
according to the space.
So if my fake place cell
fields that I just acted out
over there is maybe five feet
across, if I was then confined
to a little space,
you'd probably
have smaller ones for that
space, but I don't know.
Let me say a little
bit more about this.
So just to cash this
out, the place field
is the location in
space the animal
has to be to make that
hippocampal cell fire.
OK, so let's distinguish
that from a receptive
field in visual cortex,
which is a similar idea
but a different one.
A receptive field
and visual cortex
is the location in
the visual field
where a stimulus has to be
to make a visual neuron fire.
Not where the animal
itself has to be,
where the stimulus has to be.
So keep those ideas separate.
They're related but different.
OK, so what about we and
rodents tend to go around mostly
on a 2D plane.
That is we have buildings
and trees and stuff.
We sometimes go
up in the z-axis,
but mostly we live
in a 2D plane,
but that's not true
of all animals.
So recall the bat that
I mentioned last time.
These amazing flyers and
navigators who fly in 3D
and complicated
trajectories and yet
have amazing abilities
to keep track
of where they are over 30 to
50 miles that they fly at night
and even as they change
their orientation.
Well, it turns out that in
the hippocampus of bats,
there's a bunch of work where
people have put remote--
what do you call these
things-- recording devices
on bats, where you can
remotely record neural activity
in the hippocampus as
the bat flies around.
And it turns out that
bats have place cells too,
and their place
cells, as they also
can do this in a lab environment
where they're flying around
and you keep track of their
location with cameras.
So you know exactly where
they are in 3D space.
And it turns out that
place cells in bats
are three dimensional
because bats live
in a three dimensional world.
So whereas rodent-- these would
be a bunch of schematized place
cells for different
hippocampal cells in a rodent,
these are different place cells
for different hippocampal cells
in a bat.
Make sense?
Bats need this.
They need to know--
not making sense?
OK, so the bat is moving
around in three dimensions.
Its place field isn't just
like the one I did there.
I can't act this out
because I can't fly,
but that place cell might
fire over in that location.
But then if the bat flew
directly above it, it wouldn't.
So it's got three dimensions.
OK.
OK, so I said before
that I had one of those,
and I acted it out.
But what's the
evidence for that?
The evidence in humans came way
after the evidence in rodents.
Because as you can
imagine, it's harder
to arrange to record
from individual neurons
in human hippocampus.
Nonetheless, as I've
mentioned a few times
there are occasional
opportunities
where a neurosurgeon
has stuck an electrode
in an interesting part of the
brain for clinical reasons,
and the patient and
the neurosurgeon
are nice enough to let
scientists collect data.
So I'm going to show you a
really gross bloody picture.
If that's going to bother
you, just look away.
OK, so this is neurosurgery.
You take the skull off,
you take the dura off.
That's the direct
surface of the brain.
The neurosurgeons
stick electrodes
right on top of there.
And in this case, they put
them deep inside the brain.
OK, the gross pictures are gone.
We have just a nice
clean X-ray here.
So in these cases,
this is a patient
who's got an electrode
sticking straight
into the brain from
the surface straight
down n to the hippocampus.
OK, kind of horrifying,
but sometimes clinically
called for.
Seizures very often
start in the hippocampus,
so this is a commonplace for
clinicians to put electrodes.
And so what would you do
if you had a patient who
was willing to do your short
experiment while hanging out
in the hospital waiting to
have a seizure with electrodes
in their hippocampus?
Well, you'd have them
play a little game
in a virtual space in some kind
of-- you don't even need VR.
You can use a pretty
cheesy little video game,
and I'm sure this
one was quite cheesy.
This study was
done back in 2003.
So they had patients navigate
through a space-- this
is an aerial view of the space.
The patients didn't see that.
They saw this front view,
and they navigated around
with the joystick in that space.
And there were three visually
recognizable locations
in that space, and
they had to do things
to go from one
location to another.
OK, details don't really matter.
So all the while,
Ekstrom and colleagues
are recording from
individual neurons
in this patient's hippocampus.
OK, so here's an
example of a place cell.
So this is a diagram of the
space I just showed you,
with those three recognizable
locations and other locations
that the patient could
virtually navigate through
with the joystick.
The red lines are the
patient's trajectory
as they moved around
in that space.
And the colors
within each square
are the average firing rate
when the patient navigated
through that location.
And so this is the place
field of that individual cell
in this patient's brain as
they went through this space.
Because the firing rate
there was around five hertz
compared to three hertz
for some other locations
and mostly lower than that.
OK, does that make sense?
So just like the
rodent experiment,
but it's a person with a
joystick looking at this space
as they go through this
virtual environment,
and we're mapping out their
place fields like that.
OK, so that shows
that humans have
place fields in
their hippocampus
just as rodents and bats do.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Well, this is
independent of landmarks?
NANCY KANWISHER: That's a
very complicated question.
This patient had
access to landmarks.
They are seeing as
they go through.
So one could ask, for
example, if you did it
with your eyes closed and you
had to go by dead reckoning
remembering the
left and right turns
you had in a
familiar environment,
how well could these things
go, they would go for at least
a while.
They'd probably go
for longer in rodents
because rodents are more
accustomed to navigating
in the dark.
And they rely less on visual
cues and more on other cues.
But yeah, place cells aren't
just visually responsive.
So if we had, for
example, if we set up
a distinctive sound
source in this corner
of the room and a
different-- like say somebody
was singing quietly over here,
and we tied a dog over there
who was barking.
And you walked around in
this room with your eyes
closed, you'd have a good way
to keep track of your bearings
as you moved around because
you'd know that the singing was
coming from here and the dog
barking was coming from there.
You wouldn't be seeing anything.
Your eyes would be closed,
but your place cells
would work pretty well.
OK, so whenever
you have some basis
for knowing where you are,
no matter what modality
is telling you that--
and usually it's
many modalities--
those place cells will go.
OK, so humans have
these things too.
So you can think of the place
cell as the kind of "you
are here" system that is the
whole set of place cells.
Any one place will
only tell you are you
in this particular
location or not.
But you have a
whole array of them,
then collectively, that
whole representation
across all of those
neurons can tell you
where you are in your
familiar environment.
OK, but if you want to not
just know where you are
but you want to go
somewhere else, like there,
you also need to know
your current heading
as we discussed last time.
So it turns out that there
is a whole other batch
of cells that tell you
what way you're heading.
OK, these are called
head direction cells,
also first studied in rodents.
And each head
direction cell responds
when that rodent is heading
in a particular direction,
not in another direction.
OK, so for example,
if we're mapping along
the x-axis different
heading directions.
So the rodent is facing
in different directions
in his environment.
You map up the
whole 360 degrees,
this would be the
response of one cell
as that rodent moves around.
This one would be tuned to
this particular direction.
It would fire only when the
rodent was facing this way,
not when it was facing
this way or this way
or this way or this way.
So does everybody get how
where you are in space
is different-- that's not a
very good way to show this.
Where you are in space
is different from where
you're aimed and headed
in that location.
OK, two orthogonal axes of
relevant to your location.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So this
isn't the angle
of the head in respect
to the body, right?
It's the entire--
NANCY KANWISHER: I think
I meant to look that
up again because this
question always arises.
I think that there's
some muck about that
in the literature,
which is why I never
remember a clear answer.
Usually in a rodent,
especially the same.
Because rodents can turn
their heads a little bit,
but mostly they're going
to keep it aimed the way
they're moving.
So I don't know.
This is a long,
complicated excuse
that I forget what
the answer to that is.
But send me an email,
and I'll look it up.
I meant to before this lecture.
I just ran out of time.
OK, most of the time,
they'll be the same.
Actually, I'm pretty sure it's
which way your body is facing.
Because if I turn like this--
well, anyway, I'm
not going that way.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Have you found at
least 360 cells for each angle?
NANCY KANWISHER: You mean,
are there cells for each?
Yes, yes, they pretty much
evenly tile the 360 degrees
around the animal.
Yeah, so collectively,
that whole set of cells,
just as a collective
set of place cells,
is sufficient to tell
the animal where it is.
A collective set of
head direction cells
is sufficient to tell the
animal which way it's oriented.
OK, I think we just said--
all these things are
in a structure called
the-- well, first found
in the structure
called the subiculum,
which is part of
the hippocampus.
But since then,
they've been found
in lots of different regions.
You don't need to remember that.
So they get input from lots
of different information.
There's many different ways to
know which way we're oriented.
For example, too bad we
don't have a rotating chair.
If we did, I would have done
the following ridiculous thing.
I would have sat
one of you in it,
and told you to close your eyes.
And I would suddenly turn it.
And the person in the
chair would notice that.
That's your
vestibular system that
tells you if your
body is being turned,
even if you yourself
don't decide to turn it.
It will tell you
if you get turned.
That's another cue that provides
input to the head direction
cells, just as visual
information does
and potentially auditory
information and lots
of other kinds of information.
So many different
sources of information
feed in to inform
these head direction
cells about the
orientation of the animal.
All right, so you can think
of this as the brain's compass
telling the organism
what way they're facing.
And lots of organisms
have versions of this.
In the fly, there's
an amazing structure
that was discovered
just a couple of years
ago, where there's
a whole layout
of this little
neural structure--
I forget what it's called.
But actually spatially
in that structure,
there's a little array
of direction cells.
So actually you can see it in a
little spatial map of direction
in that little
structure in the fly.
In humans and
primates and rodents,
it's not organized
spatially like a literal map
of direction.
OK, so now we have where you
are and which way you're facing.
One pool of cells, place
cells for where you are.
Another pool of cells for
which way you're heading.
But those are just-- we're
just getting going here.
The coolest
navigation-related cells
are grid cells and
entorhinal cortex.
OK, so this is a slice
of the brain like this,
showing the hippocampus is
folded up thing right here.
And entorhinal cortex
is just right next door.
OK, so an entorhinal
cortex, these things
were discovered around a dozen
years ago, maybe 15 years ago.
And I'm going to show you a
video of a rodent moving around
his environment mapping out
activity, like we saw before.
But now we're in
entorhinal cortex,
and this neuron is
going to be a grid cell,
and you'll see why as it
moves around in its space.
Maybe.
Come on.
Here we go.
OK, so there's a rodent.
He's moving around.
That's the tether taking
the neural activity.
The white dots are every
time this one neuron fires,
we're following one
neuron this whole time.
And the rodent is moving
around, sped up video
so you can see this happening.
And at first, it looks
like completely random.
But as a rodent keeps migrating
around in his space there,
you start to see that
they're like blobs in there.
It's not totally random.
They're particular blobs
that are clustered.
And oh my god, those blobs are
organized in a hexagonal grid.
It's a hexagon.
Isn't that awesome?
That's a grid cell.
And whoops, here we go.
We don't need to see it again.
So this is a picture
of what you just saw,
the trajectory of the animal
and the hot spots in that array.
And here's a smoothed
mathy version
of where the firing is
significant in that space, both
showing you
hexagonal grid cells.
OK, so this is at first
glance a very weird thing.
Why would it help to
have essentially a place
field that has multiple
different places that
make it fire?
OK, and actually somebody
else before whether place
cells have two hot spots.
Place cells generally have one,
but grid cells, as you see,
have many organized
in this grid.
So the kind of circuitry and
math of this whole system
is mind blowing
and super exciting,
and the talk that I mentioned
yesterday was on this topic.
And many people are
working on this,
and they're working out like
really deep interesting math
about how you can
take these cells,
how they're arranged spatially
in the brain at multiple scales
and how you can use them
to do path integration
and keep track of
how far an animal has
gone along its trajectory.
It's a little bit
much for this course,
but I'll just say the
current thinking is
what these cells
enable us to do is
to keep track of how far
we've gone in each direction,
and that's really
crucial in navigation.
We need to know where we are,
not just by the landmarks
we see.
We need to know how far we've
gone in a given direction
and the thought is that
that's the function
that these grid cells
primarily serve in navigation.
And so that's especially
important for dead reckoning,
like integrating
where you've gone
according to your trajectories.
OK, so you also need head
direction cells at each point.
So you can of the
head direction cells
as telling you the
orientation of your vector
and the grid cells
of telling you
the magnitude of the
vector of how far you went.
And then you take a
whole bunch of those,
and you integrate them,
and you know where you've
gone from your starting point.
And lots of animals do all
that math in their head.
It's pretty
complicated integrals,
but they all do that.
OK, so this is
super awesome work.
And fittingly, the
2014 Nobel Prize
was awarded to the Mosers, a
then husband-wife team, who
discovered the
grid cells and also
to John O'Keefe, who discovered
place cells decades earlier.
And it's a super exciting
line of work and continuing
to be very exciting one.
OK, so so far we've talked about
place cells in the hippocampus,
direction cells in the subiculum
and lots of other places,
and entorhinal grid cells
and entorhinal cortex.
And this is just a
schematic diagram
of where those locations are.
The anatomy is complicated,
and you don't need to know it.
Know they're all in the
hippocampus and its neighboring
structures.
That's good enough for here.
Well, OK, know that the grid
cells are in entorhinal cortex
and the place cells
are in hippocampus.
That's worth knowing.
OK, direction cells
are kind of all over.
OK, so that's cool, but there's
one more cool kind of cell--
actually there's several more.
The new one I never heard of
was reported in this job talk
yesterday, but we
won't go there.
We'll try to keep it simple.
Another well-established
one is called a border cell.
So these are the place fields
of three different neurons
from an animal moving
around in this space.
OK, so you see how these
are very interesting kind
of place fields.
They're not just
a nice round blob.
They stretch around
a whole order
of the animal's environment.
OK, so does that make
you think of anything?
Does that ring any
bells with other stuff
we've talked about in here?
I think we've talked
a bunch about how
the parahippocampal place area
cares about the shape of space
around you.
Well, you might think
that you'd really
want to have awareness of
where you are with respect
to navigational barriers.
It turns out border cells
respond not just to walls.
If you put a rodent
in an environment
where there's a cliff
they can't go off,
the border cells also respond
to the edge of that cliff.
OK, so any navigational
barrier basically
telling you where
you are with respect
to navigational barriers.
OK, all right.
Blah, blah, blah.
OK, so as I mentioned
in the last lecture
when we talked about the
parahippocampal place area,
the shape of space
around you has
this kind of privileged role
in many aspects of navigation.
OK, so now we're going to
talk about this problem
of reorienting or regaining
your sense of direction
once you've been disoriented.
And so, again, I
mentioned this before.
But just to give you in give
you the intuition of what we're
talking about here, you come
up from the subway in Manhattan
or any other environment
that's rectilinear
that you know and you know which
stop you're coming at up at.
So you kind of know where
you are, but you come out
and you don't know
which way to head.
You don't know
which way is which.
So that's a modern version of
a classic problem that animals
face in their environment.
They may know where they are,
but that doesn't tell them
which way they're facing.
So just to be really
concrete about this,
so here's an aerial
view of a person.
You're standing here.
You have a cognitive
map in your mind,
and your place cells are telling
you your location in that map.
OK, so you know where
you are in that map.
And you're looking
down a street,
so you know that you're
oriented with respect
to some external axis like this.
But you don't know how
your mental maps should
be aligned with that street.
Are you facing like this,
facing north in Manhattan,
or are you facing south?
All right, so that's the
problem of reorientation
is figuring out your particular
orientation, not just
your location but
which way you're
facing in a known environment.
And we've all faced some
version of this presumably
at some point,
and it's annoying.
It takes a while to figure out.
And then I don't know if
anybody's had this experience.
I've had it only in
Manhattan because that's
where this arises
for me, but I'm
sure there are other locations.
Where you come up and you think
you're going one way, and then
all of a sudden, it's like your
whole mental map goes kaboom.
How many people have
had that experience?
It's very sudden and punctate.
Yeah, it turns out
that when that happens,
all of your neurons
flip together in unison.
Like they're all in cahoots.
They have one version of this.
When you have that
experience, it's
because they're all
flipping together,
and I'll show you some
data on that in a second.
OK, all right.
So there's a very
evolutionary old system
for solving just this problem.
And it's a wonderful little
piece of the literature
that I'm going to spend
a couple of minutes
on because it's so
classic and so cool.
And this started with work by
Randy Gallistel in the 1980s.
And so what he did was
he studied this problem
of reorientation-- that is
figuring out your orientation
in a known environment once
you've been disoriented.
It's a very particular aspect
of the problem of navigation.
So he put rats in a
rectangular environment,
and he had them explore
the environment.
And then he hid some
rat-relevant thing,
like a little piece of
food, say a chocolate
chip in that corner.
OK, rat sees that happen,
rat is interested.
Take rat out of
box before they get
to go take the chocolate chip,
and then you disorient the rat.
You don't grab them by the
tail and swing them around,
but you do some slower version.
You want to make them sick.
You do some slower
version of that
so they've lost track of
which way they're facing.
OK, now you put
them in a new box--
new box because you
don't want the smell
to still be there, new box, and
you see which way the rat goes.
And you find that the rat goes
50-50 to those two corners.
What does that mean
the rat has encoded?
He doesn't go randomly
to any corner.
He goes to corners--
he knew it was in a corner.
He doesn't go randomly
to any corner.
Yeah, Ben?
Jack, I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: Or you can turn
it around to the left.
NANCY KANWISHER: Say again.
AUDIENCE: Like it's specifically
in one of these directions.
So the left [INAUDIBLE].
NANCY KANWISHER: You've got to
say a little more than that.
What's to the left?
What's different about those
two corners than the other two?
Yeah, Isabel?
AUDIENCE: Well, if he's looking
at the shape of the room-- i.e.
these two longer walls
and two shorter walls--
he recognizes that
the space [INAUDIBLE]
he has to go to what looks
like the right [INAUDIBLE]..
NANCY KANWISHER: Exactly.
He has to have
encoded the axis--
the fact that the room is
longer on one axis than another.
And he's essentially encoded
that chocolate chip was
on the right side
of the long wall
or the left side of the short
wall, and both of those corners
are consistent with that.
That's why he goes
50-50 to them.
He can't go 100% of the
time to the right corner
because he has no information
that would tell him
that in this experiment.
OK, everybody clear?
So it tells you he learned
where the thing is with respect
to the shape of the room and
its particular aspect ratio.
OK, so now the plot
thickens, and now
they repeat the experiment.
But this time, they make some
very rat-salient asymmetry
over here.
You make a color and
a texture, and you
make other things to make this
wall very saliently different.
So you would think the rat,
motivated to find the chocolate
chip, would now go
100% to that corner
when we put them in the new
box with the same landmark
cue over there.
But no, the rat goes 50-50
to the same two corners.
And in control experiments,
many control conditions,
you can show-- and I'll
show you one in a moment--
the rat absolutely
knows about this wall.
He's encoded the presence
of that asymmetric wall,
so he has the
information that should
enable him to
break the symmetry,
but he doesn't use it.
That's weird.
You should be surprised.
OK, everybody get
why that's weird?
He could have solved this
one perfectly this time.
He has the information.
He's not using that information.
OK, so that's weird.
But then Liz Spelke
and her colleagues
came along 10 years
later and said,
let's try this with infants.
And so they did
the infant version,
where you put the infant in
a room with a symmetrical--
in a rectangular room, and you
hide the doors so the infant
doesn't have any cues other
than the shape of the room.
18 to 24-month-old
infants, and then you
hide a toy in a corner, and
you see what the infant does.
Actually what you do
with the infant is
you make this wall really
salient in all kinds of ways.
In one case, it was red
velvet, and they first
showed the-- and these
are, I guess, toddlers.
They first show them that when
you knock on the red wall,
music happens.
Totally cool, riveting
for a little kid.
They totally get it.
They know all about
the music wall.
Very salient to them.
Nonetheless, you put
them in this experiment,
and they behave
just like rodents.
They go 50-50 to
the two corners.
Even though they notice
the red music wall,
and it could have solved the
problem for them perfectly.
And they were
motivated, but they
didn't use the information.
Everybody get why that's
kind of interesting
and kind of surprising?
OK, now you might say,
OK, rodents, infants,
they're dummies.
We wouldn't do that,
us smart adult humans.
Would we?
But oh yes you would under
certain circumstances.
If we tied up your
language system--
and there's lots of
ways of doing that.
One way is called shadowing.
So it's like
simultaneous translation
but you don't translate.
Try this sometime.
I do this occasionally
when I'm bored in my car
just because it's amusingly
difficult. Turn on the radio,
listen to somebody talking,
and just repeat everything
they say after they say it.
I'm not even translating.
It's still demanding.
So you have to be
listening and producing.
OK, running thing.
OK, so that's called
verbal shadowing,
and it's an established
way to really tie up
your language system and take
it offline so you can't really
use it.
When you do this
experiment on human adults,
if they're verbally shadowing
and their language system
is tied up, they behave just
like rodents and infants.
That is they use the
shape of the space,
but they don't use salient
landmarks that could
help them solve it perfectly.
They go 50-50 to
the two corners.
They become rats and infants.
We become rats and infants.
OK, so Liz Spelke has spun
a whole fascinating big
theoretical story about
what this really means.
Well, let me just say a little
bit more about this first
before I do her whole big story.
OK, yeah so the idea
is-- so first of all,
why would it make sense
for rodents at least--
let's just consider the rats--
to use only the shape of
space to reorient themselves
when they're disoriented?
At first glance, that
seems really crazy.
But if you think about rodents
in natural environments,
the idea is that actually
features change.
Snow comes and goes.
Plants come and goes.
Odors change.
All those kinds of features
of the environment can change,
but the shape of
the environment,
like that there's a slope
like this and a barrier here
and a cliff there, those
are more stable features
of the environment.
So it actually makes
evolutionary sense
for disoriented rodents at least
to use the shape of space more
than the features-- the
colors and textures and odors
of a space--
as landmarks to
reorient themselves.
Does that makes sense?
And so the idea is that rodents
have through evolution evolved
this system for
reorienting themselves
when they lose their
bearings that relies only
on the shape of space so
restrictively that even
if another cube becomes
relevant and important,
they don't use it.
And the further
idea is that we have
some version of this system
in our heads as well.
And as smart adult
humans, we learn
all kinds of other strategies
to get beyond this.
We're not trapped
with only being
able to use this one
system to solve it.
We can use other systems--
possibly language to help
us say things to ourselves,
like it's on the left
side of the short wall.
That's what Spelke thinks.
There is some version
in your head of,
it's on the left side
of the short wall,
and that's why adults can
do this when their language
system isn't tied up.
I don't think that's
exactly right,
but it's a beautiful story, and
there's some evidence for it.
OK, anyway, part of the reason
I go through this whole thing--
well, one, I think these
experiments are cool,
but it's also been the
basis of a core idea
in cognitive science,
and that idea
is called informational
encapsulation.
So think about, it's
just lots of syllables
for a pretty simple idea.
That you have this
system for reorientation,
and it is designed to
use the shape of space
around you as the cue that
you use to reorient yourself
when you're disoriented.
That system is hardwired
to do just that.
And if some other
part of your brain
has information that
could solve the problem,
like the presence of a relevant
feature that you could use,
you don't have--
your re-orientation
system doesn't have access
to that information.
It's informationally
encapsulated.
It only has access to
the particular inputs
that are hardwired into it.
And so 20 years ago, a lot
of people went wild with this
and said that all the brain
regions that I've talked about
and cognitive systems that
we're considering in this course
are informationally
encapsulated.
It's kind of an
extreme idea that
goes far beyond
functional specificity
to say the inputs are extremely
restricted to each region,
and that's probably not true.
But there's some limitations
on the information
that each of these
processors were considering
in this course has access to.
And this is the classic
evidence, behavioral evidence
that some of those systems
have very restricted inputs.
Does that make sense, the idea
of informational encapsulation?
Not as an absolute
truth about the brain,
but as an idea that is
interesting to consider
individually for each
of the systems we study.
There's been pushback about
the extremeness of this claim
that infants and rodents
only use the shape of space.
There are
circumstances where you
can get them to use
other information,
but it's definitely true
that the shape of space
is the dominant
cue for reorienting
in rodents and in infants.
All right, so when you're
lost, as I've mentioned,
there's two questions
you need to answer--
where are you and which
way you're oriented.
This last stuff we
were talking about
is about which way
you're oriented question.
OK, and I just showed
you some evidence
for this general finding
that the geometric cues,
the shape of space
are the dominant cues
you use to reorient yourself,
to get your heading back
when you're disoriented.
But do we really
know that those cues
are different for
place recognition
and for heading direction?
So I've said, here are two
different parts of the problem.
But do they function
differently?
Do we really use different cues?
Do we use the
shape of space more
for heading direction and
maybe other cues for place
recognition, for
knowing where we are?
OK, so I'm going to
show you a very elegant
behavioral experiment
in mice that does this
all at once in one experiment.
So this is Josh Julian, a
former lab tech in my lab.
I get no credit for
this whatsoever.
I'm proud even though
I shouldn't be proud.
He was just an
endogenously smart guy
who went on and did an awesome
experiment after he left my lab
and went off to grad school, and
here's his awesome experiment.
OK, so he said, let's get mice
to do both of these tasks.
They have to know where they are
and which way they're oriented.
OK, we're going to do the
same disorientation thing.
Take them out, turn them around
till they're disoriented.
But these mice have to learn
two different environments.
OK, one environment has
the vertical stripes
on the short wall, on
one of the short walls.
The other environment
has horizontal stripes
on the short wall.
So you do the same experiment.
You bait one corner, and you
see where the rodent goes does.
Does he go to the
two opposite corners?
Exactly the same experiment, but
he has to remember which room
is-- to solve the
problem, he has to know--
he has to discover, rediscover
the vertical stripes
or the horizontal stripes
and act accordingly.
Because when he's in
the vertical context,
the thing gets hid.
He does this over
repeated trials.
The food gets hid on the--
hang on, let me get this right.
Long wall on the left.
Do, do, do.
Yeah, right.
Yeah, so when the long wall
is on the left of the rodent.
OK, that corner, the
long wall is on the left.
Everybody oriented?
Whereas when he's in the blue
context, the reward here,
the long wall is on the right.
OK, so he has to learn those
two different environments
and that the relevant shape
cues are opposite in each.
OK, everybody got that?
OK, now what you find
is that the rodent
can learn that just fine.
OK, so this shows that
when you put the rodent
in the vertical context
in a room like this,
they go more to these two
corners than those two corners.
Whereas when you put him
in a horizontal context
with horizontal stripes, he
goes more to those two corners
than those two corners.
That tells you the
rodent has used
the orientation of the
stripes to figure out
which room he's in
and hence, which
two corners are the right ones.
Everybody got that?
But here's the amazing thing--
even though in this experiment,
the very same animals
in the very same trials, are
using those stripes to figure
out which room they're in, they
don't use those stripes at all
to break the symmetry and to
go only to the correct corner,
which they could do but don't.
So once you've trained the
rodents on these two things
that the reward is here
in the vertical context
and they're in the horizontal
context, you disorient them,
you put them back in.
You find that when you
have vertical stripes,
they go to these two corners--
I'm just repeating the data.
When there are
horizontal stripes,
they go to those two corners.
OK, they've learned that.
But why do they go
to those two corners?
They learned the damn stripes.
They used them to know
which room they're in,
but they don't use them
to break the asymmetry
and decide which is
the correct corner.
OK, so this is like a
microcosm of everything
I've been saying so far
all in one experiment.
The rodents are noticing
those feature cues,
using them to figure out
which room they're in,
where are they,
but failing to use
those features, the
orientation of the stripes,
to figure out which of the two
corners is the correct one.
They're not even encoding
food is near stripes.
Like, duh, that
should have been easy.
All right, so this
is a beautiful--
I mean, this is more evidence
for informational encapsulation
of this system.
Because it shows us on
the very same trial,
they used the stripe
information to know which room.
They failed to use
it to figure out
their orientation in that room.
Is this sort of making sense?
I realize it's kind of subtle.
It's sort of simple and
subtle at the same time.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So with cells
that you showed us
in the very first maps--
NANCY KANWISHER: What
are they doing here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, exactly.
NANCY KANWISHER: Great question.
Let's look at that.
That's what we're doing next.
It's a great question.
What are the damn
place cells doing here?
Great question.
OK, let's say a little
bit more, and then we'll
think about what the
place cells are doing.
OK, so let me just restate,
cash out the findings here.
The mice are using the
features to figure out
which place they're in.
Are they in this
one or that one?
But they are failing to use
those features to figure out
which is a correct corner.
They're still 50-50
for the two corners,
even though logically they
have that information,
and they could use it, and
they should use it, they don't.
So that means the mice
are using features--
in this case, orientation--
for place recognition,
but not for regaining their
orientation within that place.
I'm just repeating
what I said before.
Is that making sense?
OK, so now David's question,
what are the place cells
doing here?
Great question.
Let's look.
It's mice, so we can do
that or Keinath et al.
can do that and Josh Julian,
my amazing former lab tech.
So again, I get no
credit whatsoever.
So what do they do?
They allow the mice to forage
for crumbs in a box like this.
OK, they disorient the
mouse before each trial.
Take them out, turn them
around so he doesn't
know which way he's facing.
Put them in the box.
And they find that place cells
have a particular location
in that box.
Not surprising.
That's what place cells do.
So here are two
different trials--
two different cells
that were mapped out
in a rodent doing this.
This cell responds
always in that corner.
Another cell responds
only in that corner.
OK, these are just
place cells like we
described before doing
what place cells do.
But now, sometimes those place
cells are off by 180 degrees,
even though the stripes
should resolve the ambiguity.
OK, so those same
cells on other trials
respond to the opposite corner.
So the place cells are doing
just what the rodent is doing.
The place cells are confused.
Am I facing--
I am oriented like this,
or am I oriented like that?
The place cells don't know,
and the rodent doesn't know.
And the coolest thing
about this experiment
is that these things are linked.
On the trials where the rodent
goes to the wrong corner,
the place cells are also
in the wrong corner.
OK, they systematically
determine
which way the animal will go.
Oh, and also as I mentioned
before, all those cells are
in cahoots.
They're all in sync
going the same way.
So when one of the cells
rotates to the opposite corner,
all the other ones rotate
to the opposite corner.
So it's as though somehow
on trial to trial,
the rodent thinks he's
oriented in one way,
he's actually 50-50
which way he's oriented.
He's not using the feature
cues, and his behavior
according to where he looks
for the food exactly follows
that way he's oriented and
so do all of his place cells.
OK, that's that whole
system goes together.
That tells you that those
place cells are relevant
behaviorally.
They are the system
that either directly
determines or is tightly
linked to the system that
determines which way the
animal thinks he's facing.
OK, I realize this is a
little bit complicated.
Does it make sense to you that
as we've been talking about
with reorientation, even
though the animals should know
from this stripe the
difference between that corner
in this corner, he
doesn't know behaviorally.
He's looking for food right
there, and yet he goes 50-50.
Weird and stupid, right?
Place cells do the same thing.
And further, the place cells
and the behavior go together.
Yeah, Sasha?
AUDIENCE: So if you're reading
information off of place cells,
can you zap it?
Can you [INAUDIBLE]?
NANCY KANWISHER:
Wouldn't that be nice?
Turns out you can't for the
reason someone over here
asked a long time ago.
You, I think.
And that's because they're
all interleaved together.
And if you zap just one, you're
not going to have-- one cell,
you're not going
to have an effect.
And if you zap a whole
region, you get all of them
and you get muck.
So you can't do that
manipulation unfortunately.
You need some kind of topography
to do the manipulation.
OK, so I just said
how all this--
I got ahead of myself--
how it relates to behavior,
but just to go
through that quickly.
So what we've done
here is they've
trained the mouse on this
classic reorientation task.
They disorient the mouse before
each trial while recording
from hippocampal place cells.
As before, given cell flips 180
degrees from trial to trial,
despite the fact
that the stripes
should disambiguate it and tell
them which way he's oriented.
And by the way, head direction
cells and the grid cells
also flip in the same way in
cahoots with the place cells.
But you can tell which
corner the animal
will go to by looking at
what the place cells respond.
And so when this place cell
represents that location,
the animal searches first there.
And when it flips around, they
search in the opposite corner.
OK, so all of that just
shows this really strong link
between the place
cells and behavior.
So to recap, we've talked
about four different kinds
of cells involved in
representing space
and navigating around in it.
Place cells that are
like the "you are here,"
they respond when you're
in a particular location.
Direction cells
that respond when
you're heading in one direction,
not in another direction.
Border cells that
fire when you're
near a particular border
in the environment.
I have border cells
going right now
throughout this whole lecture.
I've got a batch of border
cells that are going.
Grid cells that do this
amazing thing of firing when
the animal is in multiple
different locations,
and those locations
that make it fire
are arranged in
a hexagonal grid.
Think of it as a kind of
ruler telling the rodent
how far he's gone in this
space, and those grid cells
are like the rulers.
Yeah, right.
Those are the four kind
we've talked about.
So now, here's the cool thing.
All this stuff--
navigation is awesome.
We need it, it's important.
All mobile animals
need it for the reasons
we've been talking about.
But we can use this whole
system for so much more
than just navigation.
Once you have this fancy
system in your head
to keep track of your
location, to keep track
of your direction, to keep
track of where things are,
how you're moving
through that space,
you can use that whole
magnificent system
in other ways.
And in the last
three or four years,
there's just a huge number
of studies that are really
starting to take
this very seriously,
particularly the grid
cells and thinking
about how the grid cells--
I mean, probably
the whole system,
but people have been
focusing on the grid
cells and how they're used in
multiple different situations.
So here's one.
OK, this is a cool study
where what these guys did was
they stuck a little device
hanging around people's
necks, the subjects' necks.
Have a little camera
aiming forward.
It takes pictures
at random intervals
and records the
person's GPS location.
OK, so you send them
off for a few months
with this little device,
and you do something
to protect people's privacy.
I don't know exactly
how they maneuver that,
but I'm sure they found a way.
And so then they get
this set of photographs
taken from this person's front
view of wherever they were
over several months
as they went wherever
they went in their
lives with a little GPS
tag for each photograph.
OK, so then what they do is
they bring the subjects in
and pop them in the
scanner and show
them some of those pictures.
And they asked people
to relive the experience
that they had when they
were looking at that thing.
Put this on me, it'd be my
monitor like all the time,
and I wouldn't know which
experience to relive,
but I guess these people
had richer lives let's hope.
OK, so now what they do is
they use multiple Voxel pattern
analysis in the hippocampus
while people are reliving
those experiences in
the scanner by looking
at those images taken from
their front facing cameras.
And then they asked, is
the pattern of response
in the hippocampus, like
some bunch of voxels, here
is some pattern,
is it more similar
for events the subject remembers
that were nearby in space?
OK, so you do this for me,
it's like yes, I occasionally
go to the Stata cafeteria,
and I occasionally
go to the Koch Center cafeteria,
and I spent a lot of time
at home, and those
two things are
closer to each other
than my home thing.
Are the patterns more
similar for nearby locations
than for more distant locations?
And they were.
So this is the distance on a log
scale between two patterns that
result from the subject looking
at two different images,
and this is the similarity of
the pattern in the hippocampus.
Now some of you
might be wondering,
and in fact, I wonder this too.
I think this is a cool
study so I'm presenting it,
but it doesn't make sense
to me because everything
we know about the hippocampus
is those place cells
are pretty interleaved.
So how you manage to get a
pattern response reading out
a systematic location out of the
hippocampus is a mystery to me.
So they can't be fully-- there
must be some kind of structure
in there to the
layout of those cells
to enable them to
get this information.
OK, does everybody get
how it's telling you
that the hippocampus is
remembering and reliving
some representation
of the locations
of where you had
those experiences?
Everybody get how this shows us?
But then they asked another
interesting question,
and they said, oh, does
it also represent time?
So we've been talking about
space for the last two
lectures, but now we're going
straight off the deep end.
And our first step, not
even near the deep end
yet is, does it do not
just space but time?
So they can take all
those photographs
and say, OK, how
far apart in time
were these two
photographs taken?
And they can do the same
graph, and yes, they
get a relationship
with time as well.
The farther apart in time
people saw those two patterns,
the more different the
patterns in the hippocampus.
Isn't that cool?
OK, so that's one
example showing
that the hippocampus holds
some kind of large scale
representation of not
just space but also time.
And so there's a lot of work
on how this gives structures
to our memories for distances
over the range of 100 meters
and times between 15
hours and a month.
I'm going to run out
of time, so unless it's
a clarification question,
I'm going to keep going.
Yeah, OK.
AUDIENCE: Are different
states confounded for time?
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah, yes.
If you just did it like that--
so you have to do something
to pick out time things that
aren't confounded with space.
You have this big
sample of pictures,
and you take a subset
where you balance for it.
Absolutely.
They would have to do that.
I can't actually remember,
but they must have done that.
Imperfect as peer
review is, you'd never
get through peer
review if you didn't
take care of that problem.
OK, so that's the first thing.
Here's another even
more radical example.
So people have shown that
grid-like representations--
and I'm skipping over
most of the details
here to give you the gist
because actually the details
are a bit complicated.
But they've shown that people
seem to use their grid cell
system when they are thinking
about conceptual spaces, not
just physical spaces.
OK, so there's one
classic experiment
in which these guys taught
subjects a conceptual space.
They taught them about
different kinds of birds,
and these birds differed
on two dimensions.
They could vary in neck
length or in leg length.
And these things were
orthogonal varied,
so they made some
artificial birds
that filled up that space.
And so here are
some of the birds.
This one has short
legs, and OK, here's
one with short legs
and a long neck.
And here's one with a
longer neck and shorter--
wait, let's see.
Longer legs and shorter
neck right there.
OK, so you've got every
possible combination.
They didn't show people
a space like that.
They just taught them things
about these different birds.
They had to remember their names
and various facts about them.
And so the idea is that when
people learn about those birds,
they mentally
construct a 2D space.
Because, in fact,
those birds were
generated from a 2D
space, varying neck length
and leg length.
And so then when
they scan subjects,
they found essentially
a neural signature
of a grid system
representing that 2D space.
So even though the
grid system presumably
evolved to enable us to
navigate around in a 2D space
and keep track of where
we are in that 2D space,
it seems like it's now
getting co-opted and being
used for all kinds of
representations of 2D spaces,
including extremely abstract,
artificial learned 2D spaces
that you weren't even taught
explicitly as a 2D space.
You were just
taught these birds.
So that's pretty amazing.
In another recent study, they
had subjects do a role-playing
game while in the scanner.
And in the role-playing
game, they're
interacting with
virtual characters.
And those virtual characters
had different kinds
of social power and
different affiliations
with other individuals.
So here's another--
the social space
that was invented by
the experimenters,
and the subjects are
playing this game,
interacting with other
virtual individuals
who vary in social dominance
and their affiliation to others.
And they find
place cell activity
that seems to echo the
position of another person
in that social space.
I mean, that's
extremely abstract.
And yet again, parts of the
navigation spatial system
are being co-opted to do this.
I'm not giving you the details
on how all this is done.
I'm just telling
you that studies
have shown that
these systems are
being co-opted for other uses.
Here's another very charming
non-spatial use-- well,
sort of spatial use--
of place cells.
So those bats, turns out, are
extremely social organisms.
They have very sophisticated
social structures,
and they care a lot about each
other and who's related to whom
and who's doing what to whom.
And it turns out that there
are social place cells in bats.
That is, cells in
this bat's brain,
if I were a bat, that would
be representing your location,
Jack.
OK, so not the usual thing
where my place cells are just
saying where am I.
I'm watching you,
and my place cells are
telling me, where are you.
Something social organisms care
a lot about, including bats.
So they have an observer bat
here hanging upside down,
and he's watching this bat
fly over to there and back.
And then in this
experiment, he subsequently
flies that same path.
That's how we know that he's
watching that path because he
has to mimic the bat's
path that he just observed.
But while he's watching that bat
fly on that path, what you see
is here's a cell right here.
Here is the path flown by
the bat, like out and back.
And this is when the bat is
flying out and back himself,
and this is when the other
bat is flying out and back.
That blurred a little bit.
Here's the place field for self
and the place field for other.
They're not the same.
A given cell doesn't
represent the same location
when it's me who's
there and when
it's the person or bat
I'm watching who's there.
But they're place
fields in both cases.
Social place cells.
I'm going to keep going
because otherwise I'm
going to run out of time,
but I'll hang around after.
OK, so this whole
system is used not just
for representing social status.
What kind of bird this is
in this abstract bird space,
but actually for making
decisions, for thinking.
OK, so as rats run in
mazes, you can record--
we've shown this
already-- you can
show multiple
hippocampal place cells.
And can you guys imagine
that if we were recording
from several different
hippocampal cells
at the same time, we
could read out those cells
and make a guess about where
the rat is in its location.
It's just like MVPA but
done across neurons.
So we have a pretty good
sense of where the rat is.
So now we have a rat
navigating around in this maze,
and what I'm going to
show you, the white circle
is where the rat actually is.
And the little color
thing is telling you
where the simultaneous
readout from several place
cells in that rat's hippocampus
would predict where the rat is.
Like can we tell
where the rat is
by looking at its place cells?
OK, so right here they're
in the same place.
It makes sense.
The rat is right there,
and we're reading it out.
OK, so far so good.
But now what we're going to do
is watch what that place cell
location does as the rat moves
around in his environment
and makes decisions
about where to go next.
OK, so what we're
going to see is the rat
is going to come up to an
intersection of the maze--
I think it's right here.
And he's going to decide,
am I going to go this way?
Am I going to go that way?
And as the rat stays there
deciding which way to go
and the white stays there as
he sits there thinking, huh,
should I do this?
Should I do that?
You could call it
neural deliberation.
We will see what his place
cell activity shows you.
So here we go.
Rat starts there-- whoops,
how do I play this here?
OK, so rat is heading up there,
and so are his place cells.
He comes up to the intersection.
He stays in one place, but look
what his place cells are doing.
Should I go over there?
I'm just interpreting
what this means,
but it sure looks like
neural deliberation to me.
And that's what he decided.
Everybody get what we just saw?
While he's standing
there, he's in one place,
but he's clearly deciding
where to go next.
And while he's deciding,
those place cells
are essentially apparently
running simulations
of where he might go next.
OK, so we started with this
big long list of things
you need to know to navigate
around in the world.
And the neural basis of all this
is really not understood yet,
but I've shown you what I think
are a bunch of tantalizing
snippets.
Which lead to the idea
that our best current guess
about the neural
locus of these things,
which is very far from the
actual understanding of how
they work, is that
the perception
of the layout of
space around us,
the PPA and the occipital place
area are very involved in that.
Also in saying for an unfamiliar
place what kind of place
is this.
I didn't show you those
data, but you can, in fact,
decode whether you're
looking at a scene or a beach
by looking at the pattern
of response and the PPA.
We talked about the idea
that the retrosplenial cortex
may be involved in recognizing
familiar locations-- that's
a bit of a question mark.
That the idea that
your map of the world
is represented in
your hippocampus
by way of place
cells, which also say
where you are in that world.
That your heading
direction in humans--
I didn't give you all
the evidence for this,
but in humans, there's
quite a bit of evidence
that retrosplenial
cortex is very involved
in heading direction.
I guess I did give you
evidence-- patients who
have had damage there and can
recognize places but not know
how they're oriented there.
That planning routes around
boundaries in your environment
involves the
occipital place area
and the parahippocampal
place area
and that this business
of reorientation
seems to particularly
involve heading
direction cells in humans, most
likely in retrosplenial cortex.
So you don't need
to memorize all.
I mean, I don't care that
much about the locations.
What I want you
guys to understand
is what are these problems
that are involved in navigation
and what kinds of
things can we learn
with different kinds of
behavioral and neural measures.
And you may have noticed in
the last couple of lectures
that I presented lots
of behavioral data,
because actually
so far, the richest
insights about how the system
actually works still come--
or many of the rich ones
come from behavioral data.
OK, quiz is in two minutes.
Does anybody want to ask me
a question before the quiz?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Do you know
that the [INAUDIBLE]??
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah, so you
have to do lots of controls
to work that out.
And I didn't show you any
of the details of the data.
But yeah, these guys
are pretty careful,
and there are all these things--
there are many different ways
in which people are
watching hippocampal neurons
and decoding trajectories
from hippocampal neurons.
You may have heard
about replay, which is
a big thing in this department.
Tonegawa and Wilson
labs study this,
where you have a rodent moving
around in one trajectory
during the day,
and then you record
from those neurons
at night, and you
see replay of the trajectories
that the rodent went through
in the previous day.
And so there you have to be
really careful to say, OK,
there's a lot of data
and a lot of noise,
and is this really
more than the noise?
And it is, but it takes a lot of
statistical work to show that.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] scenario
be like a place that I know.
With the neurons,
the same neurons
would fire if I go back to
that environment, I assume,
or like the place?
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah, yep.
AUDIENCE: But then you
can't really have that,
or you can't reserve neurons
for those [INAUDIBLE]..
NANCY KANWISHER:
It's a good question.
How do we have enough neurons?
Yeah, especially for some
place we go every six months.
Are they sitting around waiting
for us to go back there?
No, there's some recycling of
neurons across very different
locations.
So within that location,
they'll be consistent.
But yes, you do recycle.
So the same neuron will have one
place cell in this environment,
and it may or may
not have a place
cell in another environment.
That's a good question.